oh man now erythrotol is causing heart
attacks and strokes now I'm gonna have
to change all my videos I've been
promoting erythritol for years
now I gotta redo all these darning
videos darn it all right on a serious
note I'm just being sarcastic okay let's
talk about this uh fascinating study
that was just released it's all over the
news it's all over social media that
erythritol in your blood is now
correlated to higher incidence of heart
attacks and strokes now when I see
something like this all over the news
right just out of the blue I want to
know the source of the study the who's
funding the study and I'm going to put
some links Down Below on that topic and
if you actually read the study there are
some really interesting not just red
flags but serious omissions okay and I
want to talk about them there's actually
four points about the study I'm going to
make it really simple I'm not going to
get into the nitty-gritty of all the
details of the study but I want to talk
about the four big problems with this
study the first one involves this word
called correlation correlation refers to
something that has a similar Association
usually some measurement our number it
has nothing to do with causation so let
me just kind of give you an example of
correlation statistically there's a
correlation of
99.79 percent of government spending on
Science and Space technology in the
state of Maine
and the number of suicides from hangings
so if you were to look at that from a
causation
you would want to dramatically reduce
the amount of spending in the schools on
this technology right I mean that's
totally illogical let's look at another
one there's a 94.7 percent correlation
between cheese consumption in the United
States per person in pounds and people
dying from being Tangled in bed sheets
so in other words there's a correlated
statistical increase between so many
years and this also correlates between
the total amount of revenue generated by
skiing facilities in the US so you can
see these disrelated things have a very
similar correlation personally I think
there's a very high statistical
correlation like it's probably close to
100 percent of information being put out
by the news and it being completely
false so point one correlation doesn't
mean causation this was an observational
study not a very high quality study all
right number two this study was not
based on how much
erythritol was consumed by people it did
not measure dietary erythritol at all
that was not measured in this main study
what was measured was just the amount of
erythrotrol in the blood that could have
come from your body making it our bodies
actually make erythritol it's called
endogenous
erythritol and chances are erythritol is
not really that popular so this study
could basically be just measuring
endogenous
erythritol which is erythritol made by
your own body now the third point I want
to bring up will explain number two
why would your body actually make
erythritol in the first place why would
it make high amounts well erythritol is
produced when you metabolize glucose
okay so the more sugar you consume the
more you're a diabetic the more fructose
you consume the more erythritol you're
going to make
erythritol is also made when there's
oxidative stress in the body and so it's
made when you have liver disease kidney
disease diabetes it also has increased
when you have belly fat which is
correlated probably from the amount of
carbs you consume it's also produced
when you consume a lot of alcohol so
that's an interesting piece of
information so how can we really know if
these cardiovascular events are caused
by the erythritol or by the person's
overall health and the other thing you
should know about this study the great
majority of the people in this study had
high blood pressure had diabetes they
were in very very poor health just
something you should know and number
four okay and this is the icing on the
cake
if you look up research on erythritol
okay you're going to find some really
interesting counter information
erythritol apparently is an antioxidant
it has anti-inflammatory properties it
has the potential to lower A1C blood
glucose improve insulin resistance
it has the ability to increase insulin
sensitivity it apparently in one study
showed that it improved endothelial
function and can decrease the aortic
stiffness and apparently it can even
slow down weight gain in my studies that
were fed a high fat diet that's very
interesting could it possibly be that
erythritol is increasing to counter the
bad effects of sugar creating oxidative
stress and lowering inflammation is that
a possibility so apparently if you align
all of this data together it sounds to
me that it's definitely more likely
something that's trying to help you than
something that's trying to hurt you so
you know honestly I just I don't like
doing these videos because it's kind of
a reaction to something in the news
which is kind of a distraction from
other topics that I really want to talk
about on a daily basis in my videos but
I just wanted to give you a summary on
this so you have all the info so you
personally can make up your own mind on
whether erythritol is is the bad guy or
possibly even the good guy now check
this part out this is extracted from the
conclusion of one of the studies talking
about erythritol says this in summary
erythritol significantly decrease
metabolic disorders such as obesity
glucose intolerance dys lipidemia which
is a kind of a dysfunction of your
lipids and fats and fat accumulation in
the liver which were induced by a high
fat diet in particular it exerted
anti-inflammatory effects in the
intestine yes this study was done in
mice but still it showed that there's
actually a benefit of taking erythritol
now since we're sort of on the topic of
cardiovascular events if you really want
to know what can support your heart you
should check this video out right here